OLGA MIERZWA-SULIMA:
Hi, everyone.
I'm really excited to be here.
So let's start.
I personally believe that
the future of knowledge work
will eventually be remote.
So in some sense, we all
got to experience the future
in the last few months.
However, this might not have
been what you hoped for,
because setting up a
collaborative environment
for your data science team
can be challenging, even when
working side by
side in an office.
At Appsilon, we spent years
developing efficient systems
for remote collaboration.
And in this presentation, I
will cover the best practices
that work for us.
So I'm Olga
Mierzwa-Sulima, and I'm
a Senior Scientist and
an experienced Project
Leader of Appsilon.
I have a background
in econometrics,
and my main technological
stack at work is R.
I have been building
our community here
in Warsaw since 2014.
And I plan to cover
three areas in my talk.
So project, management doing
effective code reviews,
and setting up a painless
development environment in R.
So when it comes to
project management, almost
all of the projects
that we run in Appsilon
are managed with scrum
approach with small variations.
At the beginning
of the project, we
sit down together
with our client
and collect the
requirements that
are translated to high level
tasks in the project backlog.
At this stage, we also
provide a high level estimate
on how much time
we think we need.
For example, we contract
work for eight weeks, each
with one week long sprint.
Every sprint starts with
a sprint planning, where
the dev team and
the client select
the task to work
in a given week,
and we also set the varieties.
During the week, we meet
daily inside the dev team
to give each other updates.
We also use those
meetings as an opportunity
to catch up on the
small things that
are happening inside
the team, because we
don't have those random meetings
in an office that happen next
to the coffee machine.
The rest of the communication
during the week,
we try to do a sync
using a dedicated project
channel on Slack.
We also use Slack to
give each other updates,
such as that we start or
finish our work or are
in the Do Not Disturb mode.
We also hold one-on-ones
between team members
to discuss specific problems
related to the project.
But coming back to
our Scrum process.
At the end of the week,
we do the sprint review
where do we show to our
client the increment.
Usually, this
means doing a demo,
showing the app
with new features,
or going through a notebook, and
it validates new data science
hypothesis.
We also hold
retrospective meetings
to celebrate things
that went well
or to discuss
potential improvements.
We use to Project Board
to help us manage backlog.
We usually-- we usually use
tools available from GitHub,
Asana, or Jira.
So [INAUDIBLE] development is
standard and common practice.
But making it work
for your team is a--
is a clue.
So we make sure to always
have well organized
project board that is
reflecting-- reflecting
the current status of work.
So basically, if I look
into the project report,
it should tell me who is working
on what tasks and what are
the varieties.
Also, with Appsilon,
we have this rule
that all work needs
to be documented.
So whatever you are
doing, there should
be a corresponding
task describing it
on the project report.
The task needs to have a clear
and informative description,
which is understandable
not only to the best team,
but also to our clients
as they have access
to the project report as well.
We introduced an
implementation plan,
which is something that is
non-standard to a classical
[INAUDIBLE] field.
Basically, the person
who is doing the task
has to provide a description
how they will approach the task
and get an acceptance
from another team member
before starting the
actual implementation.
This way we make sure that any
proposed change makes sense,
and we verify it early enough.
Finally, the reviewer
is responsible to check
if the solution corresponds
with task requirement.
As you probably know this,
our product management flow
is tightly related
to code review.
I will assume that
majority of you
are familiar with that
concept, and I will only
talk what makes it effective.
We have a checklist that is
part of our definition of done
for a task and includes
the following points.
All the code needs
to be peer-reviewed.
And there are no
exceptions from this rule.
So even fixing a typo
in the documentation
needs to be peer-reviewed.
We also make sure that
continuous integration checks,
such as linter, unit
test, integration tests,
are configured and passed.
Next, any added
or modified codes
has to follow our style guide.
This is especially
important because it
allows us to ensure quality,
the more effective code reviews,
learn from each
other, and [INAUDIBLE]
back in the code more easily.
Next, all the changes--
and it needs to be tested
manually or automated test.
Further, we need to make sure
that no new errors or warnings
have been introduced and the
ReadMe documentation and code
comment have been updated
according to the change.
We try to automate as
many things as possible.
And we use continuous
integration with GitHub Actions
to perform automated checks and
let the machines do the job.
For example, we
automatically run unit tests
after every code push.
We also use project templates
to initialize the repo structure
for typical project types and
use full of request templates
that contains a definition
of the checklist
from the previous slide to
help a reviewer do the review.
So finally, we can talk about
the development environment.
It's the most crucial part
when working in R. Otherwise,
the same code can give different
results on different machines.
Other projects can be affected.
As in a global environment,
shared packages
can change and crash
unrelated project.
Deployment can give
you a real headache
because establishing
infrastructure
can be challenging. if
it's not being tracked.
And last but not the
least, your team members
will waste time setting
up an environment
rather than jumping
straight to work.
This might not be a problem
when starting a new project.
But imagine adding a new
team member in the middle
or at the end of the project.
We'll solve all of those issues.
We did a development in RStudio
renv inside a Docker container,
which is fixed and
dedicated per project.
We leveraged Docker and renv
to control underlying system
dependencies and our packages.
Docker and renv package together
make team collaboration easy.
All the changes through
a Docker file or a renv
lockfile that records
packages used in the project.
are committed and pushed
through Docker Hub or Github
from where they can be
accessed by other team members.
Previous solution, however,
still requires some level
of skills to set up everything.
So some of our clients
use RStudio Server
because it allows
their data science team
to purely focus on delivering
value using their core
competencies in a highly
secure and flexible development
environment.
There is no secret recipe to
make your data science team
work efficiently.
In fact, we found
that using scrum
with well-organized project
board, doing code reviews,
and taking care of the
development environment
is essential for
project [INAUDIBLE]
no matter how your
team is structured.
Thank you very much.
And next, my colleague
Pedro will tell you
how to build a dashboard
that can speak for itself.
When dealing with
users' adoption,
you can't always
be next to them.
You cannot always be next to
them and explain how your app
will work.
It's even more difficult
when working remotely.
PEDRO SILVA: So I think one
very important thing when
it comes to remote teams is
that you're not always building
dashboards for external users.
You're sometimes also building
dashboards for your own teams
to work in.
And like Olga said, when
you're in the office
and you're next to
someone, it's very easy
to just push them in the right
direction of how to use it.
But if you don't have this
direct contact with your users,
you end up having--
a good solution for this is
to put a bit of extra work
into your dashboards
and actually
make them speak for themselves.
Especially when there's
alternative dashboards,
users typically have a choice.
And they will usually go from
the one that feels better.
So small background from me.
I used to work as
a web developer.
So I used to do pages.
I used to do applications.
And eventually, in the
last couple of years,
I landed in R and in Shiny.
So one of the great things that
I ended up learning about Shiny
is that deep down, there's a
lot of JavaScript, a lot of CSS,
a lot of HTML involved.
So this actually allows you to--
allowed me to reuse a lot of
what I used as a web developer
to actually work on
Shiny dashboards.
So why does UI actually matter?
The question is, if you
have a dashboard that works,
why should you actually care
about making it look nicer?
And the truth is
that UI, the way
your dashboard
looks and feels is
very important for your users.
So this is the first experience
that your users are going
to get using your application.
And especially now that
everyone is so used
to the way the internet works,
the way the applications
in your phones and
tablets work, users
expect things to behave
in a specific way.
It's also very important to
notice that users don't usually
care what's in the background.
And this is valid even
for some Shiny apps.
If your users use
the application
to get a specific insight
or to get some data,
they don't really want
to they don't really
need to know how complicated
the background process is.
They want to have
a nice experience.
They want to be quick and
efficient at using it.
And in general, you end
up with this concept
that if users don't feel
engaged and comfortable when
they use your application,
they might get frustrated.
They might stop using it.
Maybe they'll pick a different
alternative if it's possible.
So instead of going over the
whole UI and what you can do,
I decided to give you a couple
of things that you can look at,
a couple of parts
of the application
that you can keep
in mind, either when
you're using an application
or you're getting feedback
or when you're actually
building the application.
So I picked six very important
topics and very important
points when it comes to UI.
The first one is you should
keep your interface simple.
It means any element that
isn't actually doing anything,
you should probably remove it.
It also means cleaning
up your dashboards
and also means that you pass
a very clear message of what
you're trying your users to--
or what you want your
users to achieve.
You end up with something that
is very straight to the point,
because all the elements
there actually serve
some functionality.
Another important thing
is to be consistent.
So if you have a
text input, reuse it.
If you have a button, reuse it.
Users kind of learn to
navigate your application,
so they expect elements to
have the same kind of behavior.
They expect flows to
work the same way.
And you can kind
of define patterns
of how your application
flows when you
have very complex applications.
Another thing to
keep in mind is to be
purposeful in your layout.
This basically means that just
because all the information is
there doesn't mean that it's
being shown in a good way.
So adding white space where
there's no information
is important.
Using the UI elements
to actually create
some kind of structure, and
in the case of dashboards,
this is the sidebar
navigation, the top navigation.
All of these can help you
create a bit of structure when
it comes to your dashboard.
It also means that
you can draw attention
to important information.
You can you can use colors.
You can use the
size of the elements
to actually change the way
that your users perceive
parts of it.
Other one is you--
a few really good
things that you
can manipulate when it comes
to any kind of web application.
These are color,
texture, and typography.
So work with these.
Don't overdo it when
it comes to color,
when it comes to contrast,
when it comes to shadows.
Use them to try to attract
your users to specific points
of the application or to make
things less evident and less
important from your application.
Remember that different fonts
send different messages.
So old, large fonts
are a different message
from small, very non-bright
fonts for example.
And also remember that the size
of the fonts, the way the text
is arranged, it
really helps people
go through your
application and be
more efficient at their work.
Also remember to
provide feedback.
You want your users to
always know where they are,
what they're doing, if
the application is still
doing something or not.
Using messages,
progress bars, anything
that gives some kind of
feedback of what's happening,
really helps reducing
the frustration,
especially when you
have scripts that
are running for very
long timers or you're
uploading a lot of data.
You don't want years of to
think that app just crashed
or that something is wrong.
Keep the [AUDIO OUT]
SAM: Uh-oh.
Looks like we might have
lost audio for a second.
Let's see.
Pedro, are you able to hear us.
Looks like we might
have lost your audio.
Let's see.
I'm not-- oh,
Pedro, are you back?
PEDRO SILVA: Yes, I'm sorry.
SAM: We lost your
audio for a minute.
PEDRO SILVA: Oh.
Do you want me to go
back for a second or?
SAM: Yeah, we missed
the past, like,
two minutes of what
you were saying.
PEDRO SILVA: OK.
So some--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PEDRO SILVA: From where sorry?
ALEX K. GOLD: Yeah, this slide.
PEDRO SILVA: OK.
So I was saying that it's
also very important to provide
feedback to your users.
This is-- you don't want your
users to know that's your app--
you want users to be aware of
what's happening with the app.
This usually means
using progress bars,
using messages,
using notifications.
You should always provide
some kind of feedback
to make sure that your
users don't get lost
or are waiting for some
very long process, some very
long script that's
running, and they
have no idea what's happening.
If you have something
that you know
is going to take more than a
few seconds, add a progress bar.
If you have something that
can be done in the background
whether you're using the
application, make it--
maybe show a notification
when it's over.
All of this constant
feedback really
helps when it comes to
the user experience.
And finally, remember to think
about the default values.
Shinydashboard sleeve of
inputs of user inputs.
And a lot of the
times these inputs
can be defaulted to
some values that are
very common for users to use.
If you have a
dropdown but you know
that's most commonly-- this
is the value that's used,
add the value to that dropdown,
or pre-select that dropdown.
If you have a checkbox that
most of the time is selected,
select it by default.
Anything that
avoids unnecessary
actions by the user
and can make the experience
much faster and much smoother.
So how do you actually
achieve all of these things?
So there's two ways
of going at it.
The easy and quick way
is use UI packages.
So we're all familiar with
Shiny and its default UI.
But you can for example
use shinydashboard
to completely change the
way the application looks.
And some of these
UI tips are already
implemented in the
actual elements
provided by shinydashboard.
Another good package
is shiny.semantic.
This is base on a
different CSS framework,
but it also comes
with a lot of elements
that you don't really need to
think about some of these tips.
But you already
have some elements
that are already included.
Another option is
that you can just
create your own layout,
your own styles.
And I am giving you here
three very common examples
that I use.
So maybe you found some
HTML template online
that you would like to use.
Use HTML templates--
this is a function that
just lets you import a full HTML
file to your Shiny application.
Do you want to style something?
Use CSS.
If you have a lot
of styles and want
to go very deep
into the changes,
you can even try SASS,
which is basically
a preprocessor for CSS.
CSS for developers, lets say.
Do you want to add
custom behavior that
isn't default out of the box?
If you're building
something very complex,
you can try HTML widgets.
But for very simple
behaviors, you
can even use just
Vanilla JavaScript
with a couple of actions.
And these are some examples
of very popular packages
that were done using HTML,
which is for example.
So you can see that these are
standards for what we currently
use as developers.
And they are very
actually very easy to use.
So I'll just quickly finish
with a couple of examples
of what you can actually do.
This is an example of just
a dashboard that started
as a simple Shiny dashboard.
We then implemented-- we
then added shiny.semantic,
a bit of custom styling, and we
got a completely different view
for the actual dashboard.
Another example, and there
is a link in the bottom.
I actually did a
couple of months ago,
the whole idea of going from
just the base Shiny dashboard
into a fully complete
custom solution.
So the dashboard
started like this.
I did some testing
with Shiny dashboard
where the feeling was
completely different
with just a few changes.
semantic.dashboard-- also a
completely different feeling.
And then we ended up with a--
with a completely custom built
solution with a lot of CSS,
a lot of custom JavaScript,
and even a theme switcher.
So in general, the limit
is your imagination.
And just as a
final example, this
was my entry for this
year's Shiny contest.
There's a blog
link in the bottom
that you can follow
if you want to read
a bit more about
all the technologies
everything that
actually went to this.
This is a Shiny
dashboard, I promise you.
If you don't believe me, you
can check the GitHub [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
And that's it for me.
And I will be passing it
to Damian, which will be--
who will be talking
about scaling
and just how much can you push
when it comes to scaling Shiny
applications.
DAMIAN RODZIEWICZ:
Thank you, Pedro.
So yeah.
It's amazing.
We are going through
a journey together
when it comes to
working remotely.
In my part, I would like
to share with you how
we can scale a Shiny dashboard.
So let's take a look at the--
first, let me introduce myself.
I'm [INAUDIBLE] one of
the founders of Appsilon.
I have worked with many
different languages,
like Scala, C#, Python,
C++, and JavaScript.
And I always like to
combine all the knowledge
from different technologies
and apply it to R and Shiny.
I must say that
throughout my experience,
I have never seen a
language with a library that
are so fast to build great
looking applications that
are then used in production.
So short agenda-- I am going
to start with any introduction.
Then, I will give
you an overview
of the scaling and some
details on how you make--
how you can make your
applications faster
with just a few simple rules.
So this is you and your team.
Thanks to all the talk
and to your knowledge,
you already built the
workflow for your team.
And knowing Shiny and making
your application beautiful,
you deploy an application that
is available in production
for your users.
And then you start
having people using it.
First, this is one person.
Suddenly, there is a
little bit more of them.
And you get the feedback.
And I really like this
slide, because it sums up
our experience when we
talk to different clients.
There is always someone who
created this new fresh change
in the company.
They introduced Shiny.
They suddenly built
an application
that everyone likes.
And people just love
the application.
The features are added
fast, because of the fact
that Shiny is so robust.
And the application
does exactly what people
need to in their daily job.
And probably a lot
of you know this.
Well, however, suddenly,
you have so many people
using your application.
The application
starts getting slow.
And this is usually when we jump
in, and help companies organize
their code, and to
make sure that they
can scale to a lot of people.
Because the fact is
that Shiny's fast.
RStudio Connect
is fast and allows
you to scale even
up to 10,000 users.
But it needs to be
implemented in a given way,
with a given architecture.
And I'm going to share with you
what has to be done in order
to achieve such scale.
So first of all,
let's look at Shiny.
There are two ways that you
can scale your application.
The first one is
vertical scaling.
This is increasing
the amount of users
that you have for one machine.
And the other part is
horizontal scaling,
which means adding
as many machines
as you want, just to make sure
that the application covers
for as many people as you want.
So one thing to know is
that you should first
work on vertical scaling
so that your application is
fast and very robust.
And then you can add as
many machines as you want.
Otherwise, you're going
to use a lot of resources.
So for the first one,
there are three, basically,
key things that you can do.
First one is leverage
frontend, which
is to use JavaScript to
handle fast user interactions.
That do not change
the data and that's
so that you then have
to actually communicate
with the server that often.
The second part is to
extract computations
to handle the resource
intensive operations away
from the application.
So that-- excuse me.
Quick check-- so that
the server itself
isn't that overloaded
with the computations.
And the third one is to set
the right architecture that I'm
going to show you as well.
One thing that you
should keep in mind
is if you want your shiny
application to be fast,
and if you want it to
work for many users,
you should make sure that
the Shiny layer is thin.
This should be a
communication interface
between the data and the UI--
so the interface.
So this is really
what we see when
we join different companies
and work with them.
There is a server.
There is UI.
And there is plenty
of communication
happening between the
frontend and the backend.
And what you should be doing
to make your application fast
is first, you should make
sure that a lot of operations
that do not need any
communication with server
happen on the front end.
And that the server actually
calls the external services
to fetch the data and to
filter the data there,
not inside of the
memory of your machine.
And then you can add as
many machines as you want.
So let's take a look
at the first one--
leveraging the frontend.
Few very simple
things that you can
do to already scale
your application.
I'm going to go through
them very briefly.
First one, render inputs
in UI and only update
them in server.R. This
is a very simple thing
that you can already apply
to your applications.
Very often people create
a UI, outputs in the UI,
and then they put all of their
rendering in the backend.
This requires rerendering
the whole widget
whenever the inputs--
one of the other inputs change.
And this makes the
application slower.
What instead you can do is you
can render the numeric input
on the front end and only
update the inputs on the server.
Very simple change.
Already gives you
a lot of leverage.
The second part you can
inline JavaScript code
with (shinyjs) package
by Dean Attali.
Very simple thing, allows
you to call JavaScript right
from the server.
And you don't have to generate
the whole HTML on the backend,
but you can just ask
JavaScript to toggle
some changes in the UI without
actually going back and forth.
And the third one is to set
all actions in JavaScript
without server.R part.
So when you create, for
example, an action button,
you can right away
create an on-click hook
for the JavaScript call.
And what is important
here is that if you
have skilled people
in your team,
and you have created a
great application that
is used by a lot of people,
and you want your team
members to grow, the JavaScript
is a natural next step for them
to learn to make the
applications robust,
look better, and move faster.
Let's talk about
extracting computations.
First idea is to
use a remote API.
And Plumber from RStudio is
a great package to do that.
So when you think
about your application,
you shouldn't load the entire
data set to your application.
Instead you can ask
external services
to filter the data
for you, and you just
show the user the excerpt
of the data that is useful.
Because very often,
as Pedro mentioned,
you don't need to put too
much information to the user.
They just want to
see what they need.
Then you can very easily
grab data extraction logic
into a simple API.
With Plumber, this is done just
by adding special comments.
There is a great
documentation about it.
So make sure that you check it
out if you don't know Plumber.
And what is really important
is that you can easily deploy
this with RStudio Connect.
So just as you have your
applications running
on RStudio Connect,
with a click of a button
you can also deploy API.
And many applications
can actually
use the same API, which
allows you to reuse your code
across many different projects.
Side note-- make sure to use
efficient data libraries.
Because very often,
when you have an API,
you want to share some data.
And you very often, also
read it from the disk.
Actually, there are
many different packages
for reading data.
And you can read a
huge amount of data
without affecting the
memory of the system a lot.
So make sure you check
out those packages
and check how they actually
improve the performance.
Sometimes, just
changing the library
that you use for
manipulating data
can unblock a lot of
potential in your application.
So for extracting
computations, the second part
of this, very
often important and
crucial for the applications
is to start using a database.
To set the story,
we usually starts
with a simple
application, and the data
is just loaded into memory.
Looks fine.
I have a UI.
I have the data.
And then I have server
that filters the data
and shows the
results to the user.
Just a simple application.
However, if the file is big,
like for example, one gigabyte,
it's going to cause
you some trouble.
First, when you have
just five users,
RStudio Connect is
going to distribute them
evenly between processes.
And so they are
not going to use,
for example, three
gigabytes of RAM.
If you have 13 users, it kind
of gets a little bit more,
but the machine is
going to handle it well.
However, the more users use
your application, the more
processes you have to create.
And each process is going
to keep the same object
in the memory.
So it is crucial
for you to instead
of putting all of the data
into memory, to put it away
to a database, and
to just use filter
methods and different selections
to get the data that you need.
And then your machine is going
to be very light, very thin,
and you can have a
huge amount of users
using your application.
And the database is going
to handle all of them.
Also, important thing
to know is that you
can use [INAUDIBLE] to
use different filtering,
just as you are manipulating
data with [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's talk about
the architecture.
We all know Shiny
Server Open Source.
It allows us to very quickly
deploy the application.
Right away, after you
deploy the application,
you will see that RStudio
Connect to is a great choice
to have multiple processes
to have better control on how
users use your application.
It also has a
great functionality
of being able to
deploy applications
with a single click of a button.
What we like to
use on our site is
we use Ansible to provision
the whole infrastructure.
So imagine you have
a baremetal machine.
With Ansible, you can install
all of the packages that
are needed for RStudio Connect.
Then you can install
RStudio Connect.
And then you can even
deploy the application,
because you have a great
package, RS Connect, which
has the whole API to deploy
applications from the command
line.
So really, I think that
everyone who does development
on a high scale-- on a
big scale, using Ansible
is a really good choice.
Now, this is the
architecture that you
would have for your applications
to set up multiple servers.
And they all have to be
behind the load balancer
with a sticky session.
And they all have to connect
to the same database.
They have the authentication
mechanism and the shared disk.
As a bonus, there is also a
great option that you can use,
so that, for
example, you can have
offline mobile application.
That is using the endpoints
that are deployed to actually
connect with Plumber.
So this is also something that
we have done successfully.
So there is plenty of
things that you can do.
And I encourage you to try them.
You may think that this is all.
Of course, this is all from me.
But when you think
about it, you know
how to create a application.
You know how to
make it beautiful.
collaborate with your team.
And then you can even scale it.
But now comes the big thing.
Because when you
have such success,
then you want to share
this success with others.
And that is how--
that is why Alex is
going to tell you
what you can do to actually
go beyond one single project
and actually make
this collaboration
fruitful for everyone.
Thank you.
ALEX K. GOLD: Awesome.
Thanks, Damian.
I will share my screen here
now, and start presenting.
Great.
Hey, everybody.
Thanks so much to all of my
co-presenters, Damian and Pedro
and Olga for like leading
us through the better
part of this hour.
I'm super excited to sort
of close out here and talk
a little bit about--
let me try, how do I click?
There we go-- about growing
a remote data science team.
My name is Alex Gold.
I'm a solutions
engineer at RStudio.
And if you feel
like tweeting at me,
my Twitter is down
there on the bottom.
So let's jump right in-- growing
a remote data science team.
Just to tell you
a little about me,
this is my face, since you can't
see it on the video right now.
More importantly,
this is my puppy.
She's much cuter than I am.
And so my background is
before I came to RStudio,
I was a data scientist and
a data science team lead.
Now here at RStudio, I work
as a solutions engineer.
And what that means is that
I spend my time helping teams
figure out how to make the most
of open source data science
tools like R and Python, and
how to make the most of RStudio
professional tools.
So what I'm talking
about here is
sort of a combination of
things that I learned as a data
science team lead
and also some things
I've seen out in the
wild throughout my time
here at RStudio.
So let's start by talking a
little about like what it means
to grow a data science team.
And so there are
really four ways
I think about growing
a data science team.
The first is just
straight-up size.
Like the number of
people on the team
is one way to grow
a data science team.
You can also grow a data science
team in terms of velocity.
Like what is the
output per person?
How much Are you churning out?
How much work are
you getting done?
How many models
are you creating?
That sort of thing.
Another way you can sort of
scale a data science team
is in terms of reliability.
Are you confident that the
outputs that you're putting out
are correct?
Are you confident that
they're what they need to be?
And then, of course,
sophistication.
And that could mean
maybe graduating
to using more advanced
machine learning
models or things like that.
Or maybe it just means
going from using mostly
Excel to using more code tools.
That can be a really
great way to grow
a team in particular way.
So what I'm going to spend
the balance of my time talking
about today is actually a
tool that I think can really
help with all of these things.
And that tool of course
is the R package.
Some of you might be
thinking, like, wait.
What?
You're just going to
talk about R packages?
But I want to take
a little step back.
So instead of talking about
the mechanics of R packages,
like how do you
write in R package.
I'm not going to
talk about that.
There's lots of great
stuff written about it.
I really recommend like
Hadley Wickham's book,
if you're curious.
That's a great resource.
But what I want to talk about
is the R package as a tool
to grow a data science team.
How does the R package work for
us, not what is the R package.
But let's start off
just like describing--
for anybody who's not
super familiar-- like what
is in R package.
So R package is a way
to sort of container
up package up, a bunch of
functions that you use commonly
in R. Like much like you could
put a dog in a cardboard box,
and it would be
nicely contained.
A package is a way to contain
a bunch of R functions
that sort of hang
together for some reason.
And so I want to talk
about two different ways
to use R packages on your data
science team to help it grow.
And so the first way is
the teamwide R package.
So this is when your team
writes one-- or sometimes a few,
sometimes the team will have
several depending on what
you're doing--
R packages that are
for specific things.
And they're used
across the team.
So the kinds of things you
might-- like having those R
packages.
Maybe you have particular
analytical functions
that you use certain,
machine-learning models.
Maybe you always
weight your regression
the same way or
something like that.
And that can go--
those functions go
in an R package.
Maybe a certain plotting
default you use a lot.
Maybe you use the
same templates.
Or maybe you actually have
the same types of plots.
You're creating a
lot, and putting
those plotting functions into
R package can really help.
Maybe you have templates.
You can put code
templates in R package.
You can also put R
Markdown templates
in R package, which I think is
a really cool use of R package.
You can have a
report template that
is the same way that you
use every time, put it
in a package, now, everybody
across the team has it.
And then the last
part of things that
are really great in
teamwide R packages
are data accessing functions.
Maybe you have particular ways
you use the DBI package or ODBC
and wrapping that
into an R package
means that not everybody has
to remember how it works.
They can just use the
function in the R package.
And that's really handy.
So this is what goes in
the Team-Wide R package.
But as I said, we're
not going to focus
so much on the mechanics.
What then is this R package for?
And to me, a team-wide R package
is really for three purposes.
The first is size.
It's for scaling your
team, particularly
now that we're remote.
You can't sit next to somebody
and talk them through like,
this is how we do an analysis.
And so the documentation and
the functions in R package
are a really great tool
to onboard new people
to your team.
And R packages are
a really great tool
for increasing
velocity on your team.
If you have functions
in there that
make your work much
easier, and particularly,
if you, with every
product, you go back
and improve that R
package a little bit,
that's going to
make the work just--
every product is
going to get get
easier and easier and easier as
that R package gets developed
further.
And of course, sophistication.
If you have, say, one
person on your team
that's just a really
great R coder,
you can take advantage of their
skills across the entire team.
Or if you like one really great
machine learning engineer.
If they write those specialized
machine learning functions,
everybody can use
them all of a sudden.
To me the team-wide R
package is really a tool
for onboarding and upscaling.
That's the purpose of
the team-wide R package.
I do want to give you
two keys to making
this work for you, though.
So the first key
is that everyone
contributes to the package.
By having everyone on
the team contribute,
you get much more buy in.
People are excited.
They're excited to
use their own work.
use the team's work.
And having that team write R
packages are really, really
valuable resource, in that case,
that they will actually gets
used.
And the second key, which
is way more important,
is that your team-wide
R package must
have a clever name
using the capital
letter R. This is not optional.
It is required.
But I will give you a hint.
Blank blank helpR
is always available.
So you have no excuse for
not having a clever name
using the capital letter.
So that's the pattern
of the team-wide R
package or R packages.
Another really popular pattern
is the package per project.
That is like every analytical
project gets its own R package.
And this is a really, really
great pattern as well.
But to me, again, the
team-wide R package
is about upscaling,
scaling, and upskilling.
The package per
product is really
about reliability,
that is that it
allows you to document
what you're doing
in a much more thorough way.
And it allows you to
test what you're doing
in a much more thorough way.
When you put those
functions into a package,
as opposed to just sort of
using them in your analysis
and just sort of
having them that way.
So I do want to go through this
in just a little more detail
here, which is that--
So this is how I would
structure a project
that I were using this R
package per project structure.
And so what I would here is
I have my top level project
director, so that would
be like the whole project
to be encapsulated in this.
Incidentally, if I'm
using a Git repo,
I would put it at the
level of the whole project.
You can have sort of these
sub directories inside one git
repo.
Inside that though, I'd have
these two subdirectories out
of the package and the project,
and have those separate
from each other-- and then I'll
come back to that in a second--
but they're sort of
parallel to each other.
The package and the project
get developed in parallel.
And something like dev tools
load_all is your friend here
while you're while
you're working on this
And then you have your--
project functions go
inside your R directory.
And this is where you write--
you can put your
[INAUDIBLE] documentation.
You can actually document
all of the functions
you're using in your analysis.
And that's a really
great thing to be
able to have that documented
when you come back to it later.
And of course, then
you can also use tests.
And being able to unit test
your code is really important.
And this is actually really
important beyond just sort
of reliability that
you care about.
So maybe you just
want to make sure
your products more
reliable across the board,
and that's a really great thing.
But also in some
places, there are
requirements that
everything be tested
before it go to production.
This is a really great way to
pull some of those tests out
of an interactive mode
and put them somewhere
that you can actually
run a script.
And so this is one of
the really great things
about the project--
R package per project model.
Then of course, you have your
actual whatever the actual work
is of your project then.
Sit separately from that right.
That's in your-- you may
have an R Markdown document.
You may have an app.R.
You have some dot R files.
You might have a plumber API
like Damian talked about.
All kinds of things can go here.
But that's separate
from the package.
And so I want to stick on
this point for a minute.
If any of you are on RStudio--
R stats Twitter, there's been
a really great discussion
the last few days of should
each project be a package.
Not like the project--
the package per
project is-- should
the project have a package.
And I would say yes.
There's also this whole
debate of should the project
be a package.
And my argument is no on that.
To be clear, I spent the last
eight minutes just saying
packages are amazing as a
tool for developing your team.
But I don't think every
package should be a project.
Mainly, because you
end up with a lot
of weird metadata
on your project
that doesn't work quite right.
You can end up with some sort
of weird circular dependencies
where the package
depends on kind of itself
to do stuff in itself.
And that's really messy.
And also you can
end up in a state
where your package isn't
actually installable.
That's not a great place to be.
So I would recommend the
package can be a great tool
team-wide to share
functions across people.
It can be a great tool for
increasing the reliability
of an individual project.
It's not meant to
be a whole project.
But that's not the
intent of R package.
And I would argue
at least-- and there
are others who will argue very
intelligently, to the contrary.
But I will argue that you should
not have your entire project be
in R package.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
Just a couple-- my
high-level takeaways.
R packages are a tool
for scaling and skilling
your remote data science team.
A team-wide package
is a great tool
for increasing size,
velocity, ans sophistication.
And a per project
package is a great tool
for increasing the
reliability of your work.
With that, I'm going to pull
back up this slide from Sam,
and I'll hand it over
to her to close us out.
SAM: All right.
[INAUDIBLE] wonderful.
Thank you so much, Alex.
And thank you so much to
all of the presenters.
I thought that was a really
fantastic story, starting
from how to build a team, to
the actual tools you need,
down to what to be successful.
So let's go ahead and jump
into some questions here.
I've got a few plugged in.
We've got the first
one here saying,
could you elaborate I think
this is going to be for Olga
could you elaborate on
how people technically
work together using
renv, Docker, and GitLab?
What's the operational pipeline
here to use as a best practice?
OLGA MIERZWA-SULIMA: So usually,
how we do that development is
that when the project starts--
so at the beginning we built
a dedicated Docker container
for each project.
And inside the Docker container,
we set up an R studio.
So we do the development
inside the Docker container.
And to keep track of all of the
packages and their versions,
and to make the collaboration
for the users easy,
we use renv package,
which is the package
available from RStudio.
And whenever there is--
whenever we install
a new package,
we install it to renv so the
renv lockfile is updated.
And later, when we
finish the work,
we need to do the-- either we
do-- we comment the changes.
So we comment in both the
Docker container and the changes
to the codes.
And we can either
[? recommit ?] them.
If we used GitHub, then we
do it in GitHub or GitLab.
It doesn't really matter
which service you use.
And the Docker file--
we use [INAUDIBLE] or
you can also rebuild.
The Docker image is a push
to the Docker Hub repository.
So basically, this
is our work flow.
And how to exactly
setup renv with Docker,
there is a vignette available
from renv package that
more or less describes
how to do this.
PEDRO SILVA: Just
want to quickly add
something, very often we
also have a base image that
already contains
the cached libraries
that you very often use.
And multiple projects can
use this image as a base.
So that you don't have
to install everything
from scratch.
So that's also something
that we recommend
if you want to have
reproducibility
across your team.
SAM: That's great.
Thank you so much.
And in that, Olga are you
using RStudio desktop,
or RStudio Server,
RStudio Server pro,
what does your tooling
look like there?
OLGA MIERZWA-SULIMA:
Well, this really depends.
So either we are using
the RStudio desktop
or also, we can simplify
this workflow as well.
So get rid of the Docker.
But then, we are
obviously working
with RStudio Server pro.
But then, we still
use renv to take
care of the control
over the packages.
But it really depends from
what actually our clients
want to achieve.
SAM: Let's see.
That's great.
Thank you.
And then, let's see.
I'm just looking at making sure
we got questions for everyone.
I see.
Here, I believe this
one is for Damian.
"So what recommendations
can you make
when the dashboard requires
permissions and content
dependent on user
viewing the dashboard?"
Follow up on that, is
LDAP a good fit here,
or what other LDAP or other
authentication sources
might you use?
DAMIAN RODZIEWICZ:
So I find it to be--
there are two ways of handling
the access to the data.
One part of course
is authentication.
So who is allowed to
access the application?
And two, with
RStudio Connect, you
can actually hook
up to any service
that you have internally
in your company.
Very often, companies
use LDAP to have
the same users,
the same passwords,
and you can also have
a single sign on,
and all the other good things
with our RStudio Connect.
When it comes to
authorization, it
means that you can
have two users logged
into the same
application, but they
see different parts of the app.
And usually, this is
something that you
have to implement yourself
within the application
by assigning roles within the
app with the business context
that you have.
ALEX K. GOLD: One
quick thing I'll just
add to what Damian said,
which is exactly right,
is that one of the ways you
can do that inside connect
is that you get in
the session data.
You get the user and the group.
So that's one of
the ways that you
can take that data
in a running session
and then pass it along to--
use it to do authorization,
is that you actually get
that data inside the session.
DAMIAN RODZIEWICZ: Exactly.
That's a very good point.
SAM: That's great.
Thank you.
So now let's quickly jump
to some package talk.
I'm sure everyone loves that.
So Alex, what are
your recommendations
when functionality
should be extracted
from a project-specific
package to a team-wide package?
ALEX K. GOLD: Oh,
that's a great question.
My favorite reference
here is David Robinson
who's a data scientist and sort
of big in the stats community.
He has a very--
he says and repeats that
you should do a lot of work
in public.
And if you say something
three times to somebody,
you should put it
in a blog post.
And my sort of
corollary to that is
that if you find yourself using
the same function three times,
you should put it in a package.
So that would be
my recommendation.
Certainly, if you have
three projects where you're
using the same function,
you should probably
extract that into a package.
I would say sometimes
even two is worth it.
But to me, really the flag
is like, do I want to use
this package, use this function
more than once or twice?
Then it belongs in sort
of a team-wide package.
For the per project
package pattern,
you don't necessarily
need to reuse it.
Sometimes the testing
and the documentation
is worth extracting into
that package all by itself.
But if you're thinking about--
obviously you want to keep
the namespace of your package
somewhat compact.
And so waiting until you need
it two or three times to pull it
in is often worthwhile.
DAMIAN RODZIEWICZ:
If I may add to this,
the greater tool that
you can use a product
is RStudio Package
Manager, which is basically
a copy of CRAN within your own
organization that you control.
And you can install all
of the packages there.
And this allows you to share
this one package, which
is private to your
organization, to everyone
within the organization.
So be sure to check it out.
SAM: That's great.
Thank you, Damian.
So I think we've got enough
time for one last question here.
I think this is a question
that any anybody could answer.
So-- and I'd love to hear
what all different folks think
about that.
So what are some strategies
to maintain consistency
in file locations on the
server for data: databases,
R scripts, R Markdown
projects, and dashboards?
We have issues with files
everywhere but no structure.
So what are some
tips that you might
have on maintaining
that consistency?
ALEX K. GOLD: I'll go
ahead just real quick.
So I think a really
great solution for this
is to use a
project-based workflow.
If you look up the
Tidyverse blog,
Jenny Bryan has a
great article on using
a project-based workflow.
And so what this
allows you to do
is to sort of make projects
more self-contained.
I think that's a really
great place to start.
Obviously there are other tools
in terms of consolidating data,
and database access,
and things like that,
but starting with a
project-based workflow,
I think, is a really powerful
first step to making things
sort of-- more projects and
work more self-contained.
That and a package, right?
A project and a package
go together really nicely
for keeping things
self-contained.
DAMIAN RODZIEWICZ: The
points from my side
that I would add,
if you want to have
a great, clean code within
just one application,
I'd recommend learning
about different designs.
For example,
domain-driven design
is a great way of
structuring projects.
And it applies to many
different languages.
There is plenty
of books about it.
And they actually give
you a good overview
on how you can build your
functions, your files,
so that they are
understandable to everyone.
And the other suggestion is to
use different external tools.
So if you make sure
that, for example,
there is a package
manager that has
all of the packages
available for you.
There is a specified way
of deploying applications,
[? so ?] that if, for
example, automate it,
then the more you have--
the more structure you
provide to your developers,
the easier it will be for
them to find the right way
to do things.
So just creating, for
example, a definition
of done, how things are done
within the organization, how
you organize your work,
and sharing it with others,
can be enough to actually
have a very good clean code
within your different projects.
OLGA MIERZWA-SULIMA: What
I think is also useful is
to follow--
so you can have a style guide
for structuring your code.
But nothing stops you from
having a document which
also describes the
best practices of how
to structure your projects.
And if you see, a
repetitive pattern,
you can extract this pattern
and create a template
from which you will
initialize every new project.
So basically, the knowledge
that you accumulated
in the past projects can
be quite easily transferred
to a new project.
So this is something
from my side.
SAM: That's great.
Thank you all so much for
answering these questions.
Thank you everyone.
OLGA MIERZWA-SULIMA:
Thanks, everyone.
PEDRO SILVA: Thank you.
ALEX K. GOLD: Thanks, everybody.